Mark S:
Every time you find yourself
here, it's because you chose to come back.
(Wind howling)
♪♪
Hello, My name is Mark S.
Mark S:
And I have of my own free accord
elected to undergo the procedure
known as Severance.
(Ding)
♪♪
Mark S:
I give consent to sever my
memories between my work life
Mark S:
and my personal life.
(Outdoor noise and birds
chirping)
Mark S:
I acknowledge that once the
procedure is complete
Mark S:
I will be unable to access my
personal memories
Mark S:
whilst on the severed floor.
Milchick:
Say gratitude.
(Camera click)
Mark S:
Nor will I retain work
memories...
(Tires skidding)
Helly:
Hey!
Sorry.
Mark S:
...when I return home at the end
of the day.
♪♪
I make these statements freely.
Irving:
Hi, kids,
what's for dinner?
Dylan:
We warned you...
About the greeting?
You were kidding.
Dylan:
We hate it.
How many reasons did we come up
with?
Eight.
(Knocking on door)
Good morning.
Hi, Mr. Milchick.
Mark, could I have a word?
Petey, is no longer with this
company.
Milchick:
I'm sorry Mark, you guys were
one of my favorite office friendships.
What happened?
We'd love to tell you, but
unfortunately non-disclosure
policy forbids.
I confer upon you the advance
role of department chief.
Ms. Cobel:
Congratulations.
A handshake is available upon
request.
Thank you, may I have a
handshake?
(Rewind noise)
♪♪
Do I know you?
My name is Petey, I'm from work.
Mark S:
So we're friends?
Petey:
I'm your best friend.
Nothing is what they say.
Petey:
I used to think it would take a
monster to put someone in a place like that office.
Petey:
Especially if the person was
himself.
♪♪
Petey:
If you want to know what's
going on down there...
♪♪
Petey:
...you'll find the beginning of a
very long answer.
♪♪
Helly:
What's happening?
♪♪
Mark S:
What is it we actually do here?
♪ Daydream I fell asleep ♪
Milchick:
It's important your eyes be
kind.
Milchick:
Do you know how to make your
eyes kind?
♪♪
♪ On a beautiful day ♪